you know why i'm happy
because design is one of my favorite
segments on this show and one of the
best parts is getting to work with an
incredible designer who's a friend of
the show and drew crew member mikael
welsh that's right
let's just say he makes everything just
a little more beautiful take a look
color
lighting
organization he's the expert on all
things interior design you have great
walls and you don't look like a gray
type of girl oh two of them there's a
lot of bling i gotta control it all for
yourself and just like that honey you
can feel like beyonce yes that's
delicious he's an essential part of
drew's crew well hello
it's mikel welch his work has been
featured in architectural digest people
and the new york times and he's designed
for people like oprah and michelle obama
girl i was about to be really impressed
armed with every tip and trick up his
sleeve mikel transforms homes into dream
homes we had a little situation with the
toys i had to donate them um i'm joking
oh my god
mikel sure has designed his way into our
hearts thank you mikael thank you always
i cannot wait till our next project
hey friends
are you ready for our next challenge ooh
what is it what is it alright well i've
always believed that you don't have to
break the bank um to make your space
look like a million bucks so today we're
helping someone from our audience with
her design dilemma with a few upgrades
for her backyard please welcome belinda
austin
as well thank you for having me melinda
what bothers you most about your
backyard dilemma um okay so i have a
patio that i have not been able to do
anything with as you can see i've been
in my home 17 years i need a lot of tips
on a budget so whatever advice you can
give me
i i need help
well you know michael i like to deliver
a challenge yes and you know but i
wonder is belinda alone like to other
people let their outdoor spaces kind of
not be
realized at all let alone fully realized
um i think so i'm gonna throw my mom
under the bus she's gonna kill me for
this but
i feel like most suburban moms are
plagued with the fact that you have this
huge backyards yes it's all the space so
you don't really know what to do with it
so it's kind of like how do we chunk it
down and just start with something small
and then kind of like graduate to other
things don't take it all in at the same
time okay that's gonna help you thank
you please because i do have a big yard
and then
the patio i like this and mikael has
some budget-friendly options um to bring
some life into your space with five
items
under 50 dollars can you say that part
again that's five items under 50.
let's step outside let's go check it out
[Applause]
okay
all right first all right so you know
what drew so we have a couple of things
right here the first thing these right
here these were thirteen dollars
and let me show you what they really are
you're gonna get a kick out of this
these are actually trash cans wow trash
cans all right speaking of plants and
whatnot do you see this beautiful
expensive piece of pottery that's on the
table here linda yes i see uh it was
four dollars
four dollars
four dollars four dollars
i know right just a little coat of paint
it's just a ceramic bowl you put a
little succulent inside of it and then
it looks super expensive all right so i
want to give you one more thing do you
see anything else on here that looks
kind of like expensive
yes the lazy susie okay well that lazy
susan isn't so lazy that is actually a
piece of a round like wood round and i
added a ball bearing to the bottom of it
so literally it like it spins it's like
a six dollar kit you probably have like
a slice of wood at home i do look at
that simple easy
simple simple simple and easy
now there's one other piece here that i
absolutely love this is probably like
the biggest bang for our buck so
basically i built a lantern using dollar
store picture frames so this is
literally like me taking the picture
frames taking off the glass and then
adding a little bit of hot glue and then
putting it back together i mean that
looks full crate and barrel super
expensive
yeah very very beautiful yes martha
stewart eats her heart out yeah exactly
yeah although we love her yes
but you know then the great thing about
this i've even done one of these at my
house but i turned it into a terrarium
where i took the glass and i just like
made sure the glass stayed inside but
there's so many different ways you can
do it so many different ways so i had a
little bit of budget left and so i was
able to go into amazon and also get you
a couple of throw pillows just to kind
of like spice things up a little bit so
you can have a little punch of color
thank you
now thank you for the tips
now belinda i know that your backyard is
also used for a very important reason
and i was just wondering if you feel
comfortable sharing that oh absolutely
so
2005 i lost my youngest brother to a car
accident and every year we celebrate his
birthday in august so my backyard is the
barbecue
backyard where i've had
at least 300 people there one year
wow yeah
and really our show today
is all about you and we wanted to give
you some love and you know we want to
make sure that you know you're going
home with everything here no way
thank you
[Applause]
thank you
so much
and we were wondering if we could throw
um the party that you are having in
honor of your brother absolutely well
five thousand dollars do it
[Applause]
sounds like you have a lot of people to
entertain
i was worried it wasn't enough and you
really can't put a price on you know the
incredible work that you're doing
honoring your brother and being an
amazing human being out there in the
world so much oh my gosh i'm so blessed
thank you it was an honor for mckellen
thank you thank you but she's got to get
out of here she's got to get some trash
cans from
all right
[Music]
you